[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le premier vol c'était il ya trois ans
j'ai perdu trois doigts de doigts sont
pas sans arracher dans la turbine et la
magie s'est écrasé dans le mur de mon
atelier
c'est ça le premier volet à la norme
donc un peu plus vraiment je négocie à
ma femme pour qu'on me laisse remonter
dessus mais c'était fort que moi c'est
quand j'ai vu la machine volée je me
suis dit c'est ce que je dois faire ma
vie aller au bout de ça
[Musique]
plus
c'est pas du tout gadget parce que ça va
permettre de tester différentes
d'utilisation par exemple une plateforme
logistique volante ou bien une plate
forme d'assauts vous verrez l'effet de
surprise et est considérable
[Musique]
lou sort à travers les bus de compulsion
ça donne la poussée opus est en fait le
rider dans les airs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'un coût de se retrouver comme ça
convoqué gendarmerie soutenu par
quasiment personne prendre les
empreintes se retrouve en caleçon à
quelqu'un qui vous prend en photo les
6,4 des cicatrices pour vous faire pour
faire une fiche c'est assez vraiment oui
quand tu sors de là tu te dis mais on
marche sur la tête
[Musique]
je travaillais je veux pas tarder afin
de faire prendre de vitesse
justement par tous les gens qui sont en
train de travailler je veux garder mon
avance
et pour garder mon avance mais une zone
au dessus de l'eau ces quelques
kilomètres carrés c'est pas oui ce sont
des centaines de millions de mètres
carrés de mer qu'on a en france c'est
pas vraiment le gros souci est un petit
bout de un petit bout de deux collines
pour je puisse travailler seul et relief
en 3d
[Musique]